what are you looking for in a man now to
wear this car i'm not looking for a man
let's start there
welcome to ms mojo and today we're
counting down our picks for the top 20
celebs who shut down sexist interview
questions i just
did you do that to the guys
[Music]
it's a thing that's just feel free to
embrace your okay you know what's
interesting
they only talk about sexism when it
comes to women
when i see sexism for men i would say
more common in the media um
like for example
the matter how many how many times has
that been said on a public platform i'm
sure i'm sure there are instances and
interviews that that has come up
and yeah it's all women and we're so
oppressed okay i'll just i'm gonna try
to come in with an open mind i know i
know i know okay feminine slide mod i do
every single day if you could use makeup
or your phone one last time which one
would you pick makeup or your phone is
this what you think girls have trouble
choosing yeah absolutely
for this list what are you talking about
yes
look at i'm not that big into makeup but
every day i walk down the street and i
see a [ __ ] that's got a cake on her
face
that's not it's not sexist men don't
wear makeup
and and your phone yeah like girls are
addicted to social media let's let's
just stop capping
like criticizing part of our gender
doesn't make it sexist
anyways
we're looking at instances where stars
did not let sexist lines of questioning
fly which of these responses did you
think was the most
let us know in the comments all right
let's
okay i thought we started okay megan 20.
megan fox megan's the real deal this is
this is
actually a project and a property that
is very very close to your heart uh give
the audience a little sense of why this
one's so important to you um i mean i
was a child of the 90s in the 2014 film
teenage mutant ninja turtles megan fox
played the iconic character april o'neil
by taking on such a well-known part she
was inevitably opening herself up to
some level of critique i didn't want her
to have to be rescued by her boyfriend
or a guy like that she only ever gets
rescued by the turtles and that was
important to me during this interview
about the project
so let me get this straight
you don't think it's a little sexist to
say you'd rather be rescued by a turtle
than a man
uh maybe i'm tripping maybe maybe i'm
i'm tripping i'm terrible i'm sorry i'm
tripping
fox was asked about whether now was the
time for more women to be taking on
leading roles in superhero films she
acknowledged that the question was inane
because how could anyone answer anything
but yes do you think that i would answer
no
no
it is not realistic when you all have
scarlett johansson this five five girl
beating up dudes like i'm sorry if i'm
in trouble and someone sends a girl
that's smaller than me to help me
anyways okay i'll i'll listen i'll
listen
i would answer anything but yes
to that question
do you think i would be like no it's not
time for women to be in movies
let's take it back 50 years this would
have been a good opportunity to ask some
more thoughtful questions that would
have garnered more nuanced and
compelling responses
number 19 amy schumer
while promoting her film train wreck amy
schumer did an interview where reporter
matt tilley asked her if americans use
the word quote skanky when discussing
her character in the film do you have
the word skanky in america we do have
that word that word is an offensive one
no matter which side of the pond you
hail from and [ __ ]
if the shoe fits
if the shoe that's not sexist
i'd call a dude a man [ __ ] i would call
a guy a man [ __ ]
and just like i would call girl hoe
or i don't really use the word skanky
that's more like a a british you know
term but like
yeah
i just feel like
guys we our grandmothers
great-grandmothers great-grandmothers
may have faced real sexism like they
faced real sexism
now you call a ho ho and
hell freezes over okay or did not take
the line of questioning lying down no
but don't come on that's the character
of the movie i'm not trying to offend
you it's happening whatever you're
trying to do
you are that's a rude question she
managed to hurl insults at both his
mother and wife and made it clear that
what he was suggesting was inappropriate
i'm not leaving until we get the car
crash moment i mean that's what we would
love well then you're going to have to
get it from your wife when you go home
let's luckily in the years since okay if
you've seen that movie i've seen that
movie and i it was a decent movie like
you know she's a good actress
yeah
sometimes in that movie i liked her and
that was all her whole character was
being a hoe that sleeps around and then
gets wifed up by like the nice guy
it's like why do you all sell these
dreams to women
that's not how usual anyways okay
promoting this film the entire media
industry has learned a lesson or two
about misogyny
number 18 charlize theron
there's something feminist about this
film would you agree with that
charles tyrone is this sort of feminist
film
um you know what i think
is even more powerful about it is that i
think george didn't have a feminist
agenda up his sleeve at the cannes film
festival during a panel interview about
mad max fury road charlize theron was
asked where she drew feelings of rage
from in order to portray the character
of furiosa she had a snarky response at
the ready schooling the interviewer on
the fact that women experience strong
feelings of anger just like men do
you've got this this rage within you
where did it come from
uh
surprise women have that
she's like surprised we're crazy too
we're crap
yeah look at i think any dude that's
dated a crazy girl
you know we have right like it's not i
don't think that's sexist i just think
women
in general
don't express that outwardly
where men are more aggressive outwardly
like how i put it like
women are just seen as more like soft
and feminine and historically we have
been we're just a different breed of
women these days i don't know what to
tell you
i'm not the only one considering how
much sexist dialogue was already
surrounding the expansion of the mad max
franchise we commend theron for staying
as strong in real life as she was in the
movie george has this
innate understanding that women are just
as complex and interested
interesting as men and he was really
interested in discovering all of that
number 17 blake lively i saw that this
job
isn't just great because you get to
borrow fun clothes but it's great
because
because you get to stand for people who
need to be stood for while on the red
carpet for variety's power of women new
york luncheon where she was promoting
the child rescue coalition blake lively
was asked a question that had nothing to
do with the cause she was there to bring
attention to an interviewer from the
today show's online branch asked lively
what her quote power outfit was and she
snapped back about how clothing should
not be what they're focusing on moment
that we become more aware and that we
change and that we like
[Music]
so you can ask me another question but
she demanded whether the reporter would
have asked a man the same question and
we've got to assume they would not have
i just feel like
okay this this is what we're offended
about today
someone asked you about your dress i
understand like it's it's a
an event for like a charity type thing
um but like a good cause i get that
but
i've been to events like okay probably
not that nice that's you know out of my
league but i've been to events like that
and
if someone asked me about my dress like
i wouldn't be tripping that's
i just feel like sometimes we we'd like
want to be victims like what what sexism
have you experienced in your life well
someone asked me about my dress once at
a event that i went to
huh huh
i feel very grateful on the other hand
that we are all becoming so much more
conscious and we're becoming so much
more involved and we're becoming active
and i feel like there's an awakening
that's happening as many of you know i
was just banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible